Welcome to this major symposium.
If you're here for Beyond Genetics: Macroenvironmental
and Microenvironmental Determinants of Cancer Risk,
Disease Progression, and Treatment Response, you're in the right place. I am Dr.
Khadijah Mitchell. I'm from the Fox Chase Cancer Center, and it's my
privilege to chair this session.
Oh, there we go. Okay.
There we go. So here's an overview of our session today.
We're going to start with three talks, and then we'll have
Q&A actually after all three talks.
So I'll get us started. I'm going to talk about my work with DNA
repair and as it relates to lung cancer disparities, and really
rethinking lung cancer susceptibility
through environmental risk factors.
Then we'll hear from Dr. Maria Argos, who is a
professor in the Department of Environmental Health at the Boston University
School of Public Health, and her work is entitled "Environmental Risk
Factors for Prostate Cancer Pathology in Men of African
Ancestry."
And we'll end our session with the work of Dr.
Karen Pelka, and her talk is entitled "Spatially
Organized Immune Hubs in Human Tumors." And Dr.
Pelka is an assistant investigator at the Parker Institute for
Cancer Immunotherapy at the Gladstone Institutes, as well as
assistant professor in the Department of Microbiology and Immunology
at the University of California, San Francisco.
So this session really brings together three complementary
perspectives that collectively challenge us to
rethink how we define cancer risk and response
across the cancer control continuum, and that is from
etiology through treatment.
So for decades, cancer research has been anchored in
genetic susceptibility, and that work has been transformative,
and I say that as a human geneticist.
But it's increasingly clear that genetics alone
can't explain the full spectrum of cancer risk, of
disease progression, and treatment response.
So today we're moving towards expanding that conceptual
framework to one that actually integrates
macroenvironmental exposures and microenvironmental
architecture
as co-drivers of cancer biology.
And at a high level, this session is grounded in an integrated framework.
So first, that the macroenvironment, and that includes indoor air
pollution and environmental chemicals, shape patterns of
exposure in individuals and populations.
And second, that these exposures
interact with biological systems, including DNA repair and
other cellular processes that really initiate cancer
and progression.
And third, within tumors, that the microenvironment, particularly
immune organization and spatial architecture, plays a
clerical role in determining how cancers evolve but also
respond to therapy.
So what is particularly important is that these domains do not
operate independently. So they're interconnected, and understanding their
impact and interactions is actually essential for advancing precision
medicine as well as precision prevention,
and also for reducing health disparities in high-risk
populations across various types of cancers.
So throughout the talks this afternoon, you're going to see considerations of the
exposome. So the Human Genome Project was launched in
1990, and this really revolutionized the way that we understood
and treated cancer.
So it allowed us to go from discovery and transform that to
delivery.
And the Human Exposome Project was launched in
2025, and it's poised to do the same.
So this time, instead of the focus being on genes
alone, it's the totality of exposures that shape your
cancer risk across the lifespan.
So you may ask yourself, well, how do we define the exposome?
So akin to the genome being an entire set of DNA
instructions, the exposome represents the cumulative
environmental exposures and individual experiences over time.
So when we integrate the genome and the exposome,
we begin to better understand how cancer develops in specific
individuals and populations, but also how this extends to other
omic layers.
And so we're really at an inflection point that's driven
by these factors, the convergence of AI,
advanced sensor technologies and actually
exposomics maturing as a field, it's been
around for about 20 years, and big data analytics that now
allows us to measure the exposures at scale.
So what was conceptually important 20 years ago when the exposome
was first proposed is now technically possible.
So the exposome can include internal exposures, such
as immune system changes, like Dr.
Pelka is going to talk about,
or external exposure, such as environmental chemicals or
radon, like Dr. Argos and myself will discuss.
So our goal is by the end of this session, that my
colleagues and I hope that you'll have a better appreciation of the
importance of studying macroenvironmental as well as
microenvironmental risk factorsfor cancer outcomes
along the translational research continuum.
So that includes translation to humans, patients,
practice, as well as communities.
Thank you, Thomas.
To get us started, I'm going to share my work on thinking about
biological and environmental risk factors and how they can help us
rethink who gets lung cancer and why.
So unfortunately, I have no financial relationships to disclose, but I'm working on
that. Maybe next year.
So on the left, you see a depiction of the social ecological model,
which is a multilevel framework used to better understand factors
that interact and influence health outcomes.
So my lab focuses on individual, community, and
policy interventions that target lung cancer prevention and treatment.
So we really endeavor to make discoveries that go from the bench to the
bedside in the clinic. And in that way, we study population
differences in lung cancer genomics,
for precision prevention and precision medicine goals.
And we really consider biological, environmental, and behavioral
determinants of health.
But we feel it's equally important that you translate those findings from the bench
to the block. So we do this through community-based participatory
research and community engagement research.
And in this capacity, we work to increase
knowledge about prevention, so whether that's primary, secondary, or
tertiary prevention, diagnosis, prognosis, and treatment.
And a lot of that work, we do that with faith-based organizations and
community-based organizations.
And then finally, I work as an advisor for our Pennsylvania Department of
Health, Office of Health Equity, and in that way, I really work to frame lung
cancer prevention and control initiatives with a special emphasis on racial and
ethnic minority populations, and the policies that affect them through
primordial prevention. And if you're not familiar with primordial prevention,
that is preventing the development of the risk factors initially in the first
place. So in this capacity, I work with advising the Office of Health
Equity director, as well as the Secretary of Health.
And when you think about how do we translate these findings from the
lab and the community, we really focus on basic research
going to translation to humans, so T1 to T2 in
patients, but then also translation to community.
And so just as an overview of my talk today, I'm going to start with
background just to frame the disease context about lung cancer and lung cancer
disparities, and then I'm going to move and propose a novel genomic
risk factor, particularly homologous recombination deficiency and
how that relates to radon exposure.
So in the US,
or excuse me, globally, we know that lung cancer has the highest incidence and
mortality rate. It actually has surpassed breast cancer recently, according to the
most recent Global CAN data.
And when you look here in the US, it's the third most common behind breast
cancer in females and prostate cancer in males, and it remains the leading
cause of mortality.
And while lung cancer impacts
all races and sexes, it does not affect them equally.
So collectively, African Americans are shown here in red,
and European Americans are shown here in gray.
We see that African Americans tend to have a greater burden, so higher
incidence, mortality, and lower survival.
And a lot of this is driven by differences between African American and European
American males.
We also know that this population tends to be diagnosed at later stages
than European Americans, as denoted by the red box there,
distant stages.
And they're also more likely to be diagnosed at earlier ages.
The median age of diagnosis is 68 years for African
Americans, and it's 72 years for European Americans.
And even when you consider early onset cancer, so less than 50 years of
age, this population has higher rates of diagnosis.
So the burning question is: What could be driving these population differences?
So I think
myself and others have previously shown that it's the interaction of
these factors, so both non-biological and biological in scope.
The first thing that people typically think is due to smoking, right?
But actually, African Americans have lower cumulative tobacco exposure compared
to European American counterparts.
So we have what's called the African American smoking paradox.
So it's not smoking alone.
Menthol cigarette smoking, so when African Americans do smoke, they smoke a menthol
cigarette about 85% compared to 30% of European Americans.
And so it's harder to quit a menthol cigarette, so that could partially
explain some of the disparities, but not completely.
Geography, so a lot is known about environmental exposures in environmental justice
areas. So African Americans tend to live in environmental justice areas, and
there's higher risk of lung cancer.
But also political factors, so socioeconomic status, access to healthcare and
screening, and systemic and structural discrimination.
Biological risk factors, recent studies have shown genomics as
well as other omic layers. But the thing that is
the least studied is the environmental exposures and the genomics.
And so our work is really working to fill that gap.
So we've shown that,
for risk, rural counties living in a rurality,
increasing rurality is associated with more greater levels of
disparities, as well as particular genetic variations and
genetic ancestry has been associated with increased risk in this population,
as well as unique somatic mutations, copy number alterations,
and loss of heterozygosity and genomic
instability has been associated with different treatment
responses.And so when we
think about
the genomics and then crosstalk with the environment, we
know that radon gas exposure and air pollution
actually leads to DNA double-strand breaks, and this is the most
severe type of damage.
And so there's a pathway, the homologous recombination repair pathway,
that fixes these damage. And when you have normal HR repair, it restores the
normal alleles. However, if you're deficient in this process,
then you get genome-wide alterations.
And in this regard, you have what's called HRD, homologous
recombination deficiency. And HRD-positive tumors
respond to the PARP inhibitor treatment, and we know this is a pan-cancer
phenotype associated with various cancers, so breast, ovarian,
prostate, as well as pancreatic cancers.
But studying HRD in the lung cancer context
has had unmet potential. Recent studies have shown that a
subset of lung cancer patients, shown here above the red horizontal line,
show robust signs of both somatic and germline
HRD.
And similarly, our work has shown that African American non-small
cell lung cancer patients have a signature, HRD
signature, and we think that this could be a novel genomic risk
factor. So we've identified somatic changes in this
pathway. So when performing mutational profiling, we saw
11 dominant cosmic mutational signatures in this
population, and HRD was the third most common mutation
signature.
And in a subsequent genomic profiling study, we also observed
higher somatic changes in this pathway.
When we compared African Americans to European Americans, we saw
that they were more likely to have this particular phenotype.
And this was more significant in lung squamous cell carcinoma compared to lung
adenocarcinoma.
When we expanded this to perform a pan-cancer analysis, interestingly,
we saw that African Americans had higher somatic HRD
frequencies across 13 out of 23 different cancer types.
And when we shifted to look at germline changes, we saw a
similar finding that African Americans had higher germline HRD
frequency across 13 out of 17 types, including lung
cancer. And again, we saw that it was more significant in the lung squamous
cell histology. So because these unrelated
individuals had
this higher frequency of this phenotype, we posited that
genetic ancestry could be involved.
So this led us to hypothesize that genetic ancestry was associated
with population-specific germline pathogenic variants in this
pathway in lung cancer.
And so our first aim, we wanted to identify ancestry-enriched
germline pathogenic variants in the HR repair pathway, and
then to assess the functional consequences of this.
So to address our hypothesis and aims, we used
germline genomic data for 1.1 million individuals
across six genetic ancestry populations in the gnomAD
Discovery and the All of Us validation cohort.
And we looked at frequency, we looked at functional impact, and the clinical
relevance of these GPVs across 88 HR
pathway genes.
And what we discovered was that there were 37
ancestry-enriched GPVs across 27 out of 88 of these
repair genes, and all of these were annotated in ClinVar.
And so these variants were predominantly frame shift alterations
in conserved regions, as you can see by the purple here on the right.
And so the genetic ancestry population is on the x-axis, and then the
frequency is on the y-axis. And one thing to point out, the
Middle Eastern and South Asian genetic ancestry groups also had a higher proportion
of in-frame deletions.
So we were curious if these ancestry-enriched GPVs were
associated with HR repair pathway in lung cancer.
So to test this, we looked at statistically significant
associations with lung cancer. We queried our 27 gene
set in these ancestry-enriched GPVs in cases and controls.
And to ensure adequate statistical power, we used things that only had 200 cases or
more, which restricted the analysis to African and European ancestry
populations.
So in addition to the HR pathway,
there are three other pathways that work to repair DNA double-strand breaks.
So there's non-homologous end joining
here, there's alternative end joining, and there's
single-strand annealing. And so what we did was we looked at all
four of these pathways to see if there was enrichment.
And what we saw was that two of them, so again, HR and
non-homologous end joining, were predominant.
And so just to help you with this picture on the right,
there are four colors. So the things that are in this turquoise color
denote HR as the more enriched pathway, and this orange
color denotes NHEJ. So again, we saw that HR was more
predominant, and you can see in the African ancestry
compared to even European ancestry.
When we think about the shapes, so the things that are circled are
shared with both genetic ancestry groups, so we see that these particular
genes were shared across populations.
But when you see the triangle, these are things that were more enriched in
African ancestry, and the squares were things that were more enriched in
European ancestry. So in line with our talk, we
know that there is some link between genetic
ancestry, in particular, the pathway or
the environmental exposure that tends to be activated, which is
HRin response to radon and air pollution.
So in line with that, in translation to humans and
patients, we recently, I'm a part of a team, an
international interdisciplinary team that was awarded a Canadian Institutes of
Health Research grant of Bridging Biology to Cancer Prevention.
And we're looking at radioactive air pollution-induced disease,
particularly the radon exposome.
So we're looking at cumulative exposure of radon as well as air pollution,
and how this genetic ancestry and the DNA repair capacity that I just showed
you is related to the exposure. And also
mixed exposure, so combustible particulates, we mean wildfire
smoke.
And so we have teams from across Canada as well as the US, so Fox
Chase and Harvard Chan School of Public Health.
And so a little more about, then, this genetic susceptibility, this
biological susceptibility to the environmental exposure.
Why are we interested in radon?
So like I mentioned, radon induces DNA double-strand breaks, and it's been known
for decades that this exposure preferentially, or this pathway
preferentially is upregulated to repair the type of alpha radiation
damage that comes from this environmental exposure.
And just to put it into context, if you think
about low health risk is if your home measures
radon in the range of zero to 1.9 picocuries per liter.
If your home measures two to 3.9, it's a medium health risk for developing lung
cancer. And most recently, the high health risk is four
picocuries per liter. And so what does that translate to tobacco
exposure? So when you think about four picocuries, which is the high
risk, is the equivalent of being exposed to half a pack of cigarettes a day.
And comparing that to 10 picocuries is about a pack a day.
So radon is a naturally occurring odorless, colorless, and
tasteless gas, and it decays and produces further radioactive
particles, and this is what induces DNA damage in our lungs.
So radon actually causes 3% to 4% of all lung cancer cases.
In never smokers, it's the leading environmental cause of the disease.
And in smokers, it's actually synergistic.
So your
risk increases 25 times higher than in a non-smoker.
And so in this graph on the left, what I'm showing you is that the US EPA
Zone 1, again, four picocuries per liter or higher, is shown here the highest
potential for developing a health problem.
And we see that about 31% of the country lives in a
Zone 1.
When you think about the state in which I live and serve, Pennsylvania,
we have the third highest radon levels in the country, and 40% of
Pennsylvania homes actually sit in a EPA Zone 1, which is shown
here by red. And because these levels vary by county,
our state cancer control plan, which is funded by the CDC, actually
explicitly includes radon risk reduction strategies.
And we also know that in even smaller geographic scales, we see variation in
radon. So here, these are all high radon areas, and this is
variation across the three most populated counties
in Pennsylvania. And so we can see that a range of
anywhere from 10% to 90% of homes in any given ZIP
code can have high radon.
And even though radon is a modifiable risk factor, Pennsylvania has the
fifth-worst radon testing disparity in the US.
And so
we know that that burden, in particular, some communities are less likely to
test, so racial and ethnic minorities, lower
income, and renters. And we see extreme testing disparities
that could then exacerbate lung cancer disparities because there's
increased environmental carcinogen exposure.
So in response to address these disparities,
I founded the Radon Health Equity Work Group.
And so this is a multidisciplinary professional alliance.
It has nonprofit members, industry, government, and academic partners
from across the state, and we all are dedicated to radon risk reduction.
So we have four pillars. So it's education, testing, mitigation, and
research. And so we define radon health equity as a
situation in which all people have equal access to risk reduction,
education testing, mitigation, and research to prevent lung cancer.
And so we work from this framework.
So we've started our own lung cancer prevention framework, which addresses
disease stage from underlining to post-clinical, target
populations from healthy to those with a diagnosis, and
actionable solutions from radon policies to identification of
novel biomarkers. And using this framework, we came up with
a community engagement study design where we hypothesized that free or low-cost
community-based testing would reduce radon testing disparities in high
radon areas. And so our first aim is to identify high-risk
communities in high radon areas, but also environmental justice.
And then second, to partner with local libraries to pilot a
novel community-based radon library lending program.
And so we've identified 57 high-risk communities based on three
criteria: high radon, they have to have
disparate testing rates, and also to be in an environmental justice
area.
And so these circles are denoting where we have 40 high-risk ZIP
codes in the Pittsburgh area, 11 in Harrisburg,
and six in the Philadelphia area.
And we've already identified radon library partners in these areas.
And the reason we're partnering with libraries, we know for a fact that
racial and ethnic minority communities have high rates of
medical mistrust and actually lack
access to healthcare, but public libraries are trusted sources of
information. They have fewer barriers to access.
In fact, 96% of the US population lives in a public library service
area. That includes urban and rural areas.
And they really bridge the digital divide because access to the internet.
And in the literature, they're emerging sites for various health
initiativesAnd so our
translation to communities is we recently received the
CDC Department of Health Environmental Health Capacity Building Grant to
enable the Pennsylvania Care Studies, Pennsylvania Community
Access to Radon Health Equity Solutions.
And with this, we're getting funding for a community education
webinar, a culturally and linguistically appropriate radon exposome
fact sheet and infographics to tailor community-based radon
testing and to create a refined radon testing disparity metric.
And similar to
the work that I've shown in the wet lab, we're talking about the
exposome from a community perspective.
And then finally, translation to population.
So
we are part of a Radon in Schools work group where we have the
opportunity to co-author and provide recommendation for bill language
to state legislators. And we currently have a bill that's in
session that is seeking to test radon in all K through 12
schools.
And so I'll end the way that I started in thinking about
interventions. So from the bench to the bedside, we obviously would like
to discover genetic variants, but how they interact with radon
exposure in high-risk populations to expand our
pilot project statewide. So we've been talking with the Department of
Health to do that, but to also continue leading policy
efforts as the chair of the Radon Health Equity Work Group.
And with that, I'd like to thank the organizers for the opportunity to speak today,
as well as acknowledge
you all, the funding, all the folks in my lab,
as well as my collaborators.
And now I'll call to the podium Dr. Argos.
Thanks very much. All right. So thank you so much to Dr.
Mitchell for the invitation to
present to you today and for organizing this session.
I have no disclosures to report. So the topic
that I'm going to be presenting on today is
an international collaboration that I'm a part of,
looking to characterize environmental risk factors for prostate
cancer-related pathology among men of African ancestry.
So just to provide some context to this work,
using data also from Globocan,
we see that there's significant variability across the world with
respect to prostate cancer incidence,
with many regions in Africa showing high incidence
to prostate cancer.
However, we see a large disparity with respect to prostate
cancer mortality as well. And so looking at the
ratio of prostate cancer incidence to mortality, we see that
there's a notable disparity among
countries in Africa, notably South
Africa, Namibia, Nigeria, and Kenya, which is where some
of this work is taking place.
And when we look at some of the factors that potentially may
explain this disparity that we see, we can
attribute
perhaps a small percentage of this disparity to germline
genetics
and also to access in healthcare. However, what's been
relatively understudied and undercharacterized is the role
of environmental factors in contributing to
these disparities that we see in prostate cancer geographically
and across different ancestries across the world.
And so with funding from the Department of Defense
Health Equity Research and Outcomes
Improvement Consortium Award, the Prostate Cancer
Precision Health Africa 1K project was
established. This is under the leadership of Vanessa
Hayes at the University of Sydney.
And so the goal of this project is to generate a
resource
among men of African ancestry who are recently diagnosed
with prostate cancer to gather, in a systematic manner,
clinical and pathology data, to collect
through questionnaires lifestyle data, to collect
biospecimens to characterize biochemical and exposure data,
and then to also characterize genetic data, both
germline and somatic. And so really the goal of this consortium
is to identify external factors that act as drivers that
contribute to increased tumor mutational
burden of prostate cancer in
African men.
And so
this team is a partnership across many collaborators.
Dr. Peter Ngugi leads the urology and
pathology component of this project.
He is located at the University of Nairobi in Kenya.
We have a group focusing on public health and
awareness. This is under the leadership of Dr.
Riana Borman, who's at the University of Pretoria in South
Africa.
At the University of Illinois, Chicago,
working primarily in the area of exposomics and endocrinology,
the project is led by Dr. Gail Prins, and I help co-lead this
component.
And then the genomics and data science component is led by Dr.
Vanessa Hayes, who's at the University of
Sydney.And so, just to
give you a glimpse into some of the areas that we're working with,
for example, the South Africa Prostate Cancer
Study largely recruits participants from three regions
across South Africa. This includes Pretoria, which is largely
an urban area, so we are particularly interested in
characterizing industrial exposures among men
recruited from this site.
Bojanala is an area where there's extensive mining
activity that's conducted, primarily platinum mining.
And then Vhembe, which is in the northern region of the country.
This is a largely agricultural area.
So even within the country, we have great diversity in terms of the
environmental exposures that we expect to see.
Similarly in Kenya, we recruit from three different sites,
including Nairobi. Again, this is primarily industrial exposures.
The Mount Kenya region, which is characterized by coffee
plantations.
And then the Eldoret region, which is sort of a mix of
rural-urban, with agricultural activity
occurring in this area.
And so some of the work
in the first phases of this consortium that this group has
shown is one, just looking at the
tumor mutational burden within samples that are collected
from participants in this study.
So in this early publication, using data from
123 South African
men, seven men from Brazil, and then 53
individuals from
Australia who are largely European ancestry,
the group was able to characterize two million somatic
mutations using whole genome sequencing within
the prostate tumors. And was able to show using
that data that there was a much greater tumor
mutational burden among men of African ancestry.
And then also using the
mutational data, looking at the molecular
taxonomy of the prostate cancers.
And so
using the global mutation subtypes framework,
showing that there were global mutational subtypes that
were specific to African ancestry populations.
And so
while we believe that genetics potentially contributes to some
extent to tumor mutational burden, the
external environmental characteristics leading to
these factors has largely been understudied.
This was another early study that was published using a
subset of the
tumor mutational data focusing on genes related
to epigenetic machinery.
And so again, looking across different ancestry populations, it
was shown that among these
genetic drivers, 63 of these were specific to
African ancestry populations. Nine of these were
ancestrally shared, so identified to be present in both African and
European ancestry individuals. And only one of
these driver mutations was observed to be European
specific. So again, showing a much
stronger burden of
epigenetic
associated mutations among African ancestry
individuals.
And then looking at
the epigenome-wide signature within the tumor
itself.
The group has also shown that there is significant
hypermethylation when you look at the epigenomic
profile of prostate tissues collected
from men of African ancestry relative to individuals
of European ancestry. So this is sort of the genetic and
molecular basis of some of the work that the consortium
is conducting. And so
one last element of this is also trying to understand
geographic factors that are contributing to some of these
differences. So for example, there's been work looking within
South Africa itself to try to characterize some
of the urban-rural differences that are being observed.
So beyond just thinking about access to healthcare, what are some other
factors that might be contributing to the differences?
So as I mentioned, using the tumor mutational data,
the group has identified
genetic
mutational subtypes. And so even just looking within South
Africa, we see that there is a notable
difference with respect to these molecular taxonomies that
we observe among individuals living in the rural region versus
those living in
urban areas of the country. With individuals in
the rural areas of the country having
a molecular subtype that's characterized by copy number losses,
which generally has been associated with poorer prognosis of
prostate cancer within these individuals.
So trying to understand within the country what are some of the factors that are
contributing to this
disparity.So the current phase of our
work now is focused on overlaying environmental
factors on the existing genetic and molecular data within the
consortium. And so focusing to the best that we can on this
exposomics framework, where we're looking broadly at
different chemicals and features of the environment
that may be contributing to
developing prostate cancer, developing more aggressive
prostate cancer, and then contributing to
higher
case fatality.
And so
similarly, when we think about
what the
public health and clinical implications of this work are,
our hope is to be able to integrate environmental
factors with genetic information,
tumor information to be able to
reduce disease onset, so decrease the risk of
prostate cancer developing.
Among individuals who already have signs of disease
development, to be able to slow down progression or to switch to
potentially a pathway that leads to less aggressive disease,
and then to also be able to provide information to improve
prognosis among individuals that develop prostate cancer.
And so
really, I think, our ultimate goal is to try to
characterize the exposome within these individuals.
And I will say, if we define the exposome as the
totality of exposures across the life course,
in practice, this is actually very difficult
to do. And so,
currently what we're trying to
do within this
research program is to at least focus on characterizing the
physical and chemical
environment of individuals around the time of their
disease diagnosis. So using that as a starting point,
and then hopefully in the future, having the ability to build
out
information on historical exposures or exposures to other features of the
environment.
And so our initial focus as a research group has been
characterizing a broad spectrum of chemicals that we consider to be
endocrine-disrupting chemicals.
For those that may not be familiar with this class of chemicals,
these are exogenous chemicals that are known to alter
hormone activity.
In the context of prostate cancer, this is important when we think about
androgens and estrogens,
and particularly when exposure to these chemicals occurs
during critical windows of either prostate development or adult
homeostasis.
So it can contribute to prostate cancer
development by disrupting cellular, epigenetic, or
microenvironmental processes that can increase susceptibility
to cancer developing, the progression of cancer, the
recurrence of cancer.
So, it's been shown that
endocrine-disrupting chemicals can either mimic,
block, or alter the synthesis release, transport,
metabolism, binding, or elimination of
endogenous hormones that regulate prostate growth and differentiation.
And there have been many chemicals that are ubiquitous in the environment that have
been well-characterized as endocrine-disrupting chemicals.
So some of these that you may be familiar with are compounds
like bisphenol A, various phthalates that are used as
plasticizers,
legacy exposures like PCBs, various
pesticides, and then an emerging class of chemicals that we're
becoming increasingly concerned with, known as
PFAS, as well as a subset of metals that are known to have endocrine-disrupting
activity as well.
And so there have been a number of mechanisms related to
exposure to endocrine-disrupting chemicals that are
associated with potentially the development of prostate
cancer,
including alterations to cell proliferation or
apoptosis, contributing to inflammation,
changes in prostate size or histology,
altering hormone receptor expression or signaling,
contributing to
somatic mutations or epigenetic changes, and
then modulation of the tumor microenvironment.
And so, while
I think there's very strong experimental data to
support the association of these chemical exposures
with prostate cancer in general, I would say that the
epidemiologic evidence is very mixed.
So it's been difficult for many reasons
to really characterize the role of these chemicals
within the context of prostate cancer.
And so,
I think some of the challenges that this consortium is primarily
focused on
contributing,
I think, novel data to is thinking about the role
of genetic susceptibility in the context of exposure to
these chemicals. So when we look at exposure within an
average population, we may be missing important
environmental signals that when we're not looking
among genetically susceptible individuals,
we may not be able to capture well or characterize well.
The other consideration is thinking about disease aggressiveness.
And so, similar to other risk factors like obesity,
endocrine-disrupting chemicals may be specifically contributing to more
aggressive prostate cancers. And so,
focusing our investigations among
that subpopulation of individuals.
And then finally, thinking about
what pathways or molecular data would
help strengthen the evidence within human studies
that endocrine-disrupting chemicals are contributing
to
cancer initiation.So from
an environmental epidemiologic perspective, I
also think that this is a particularly challenging
topic of study because we know that timing of exposure
may be critical to many of these hypotheses.
And so, for example, if exposure occurs during sensitive
periods like the prenatal period,
the perinatal period, or during puberty, individuals may
be particularly susceptible to the effects of those chemical
exposures during those particular life periods.
And so we need to be, I think, very deliberate in terms of when
we're measuring exposure and how we're relating it to
disease outcome.
The other consideration is that endocrine-disrupting
chemicals are known to have effects even at low doses of
exposure. And these associations may not
necessarily be monotonic, which means that if we have
data on high-level exposures, that may not necessarily
inform what the association will be in the low dose
range and vice versa. And so ensuring that we have
more comprehensive data for exposures
within
the complete dose response range.
The other consideration is thinking about environmental mixtures.
So much of the epidemiologic literature has focused on single
chemicals in isolation, looking at the effects of an individual metal
or
BPA individually. But we know that individuals are not
exposed in the real world to a single environmental exposure at a
time. And so thinking about this within a framework where we can
study the mixture as a whole or
a more representative representation of somebody's environmental
exposures more comprehensively.
Other characteristics that we need to consider is that many of these chemicals
have very short half-lives. So unless somebody has chronic
exposure to these environmental exposures, using
either a single
urine or blood sample at a single moment in time may not
be a good characterization of somebody's exposure to that
particular chemical. And so thinking about what is the context
that somebody is being exposed to and
how well are we capturing it with the exposures that we're measuring.
And then, I think with much of the
work that's being done in cancer epidemiology, taking latency into
consideration. And so,
what is the relevant exposure window for many of these
environmental factors contributing to cancer development?
So
just for the sake of time, I'll move on to the specific environmental assays that
we've prioritized within this consortium.
We have collected toenail clippings from all
participants in the study, and we use these toenail clippings as a measure
of
longer-term exposure to a wide panel of metals.
We also collect urine samples and plasma
samples that
we've prioritized looking at DDT and DDE exposures within
the population. So while use of this chemical was
banned in the United States in 1972, it's still
used in certain regions of Africa for malaria control.
So we know that there's ongoing exposure to
this particular compound. We're also
interested in looking at the effects of pyrethroids.
These are largely used as insecticides as well as
some organic pesticides.
In addition to the targeted environmental assays that we're conducting, so
these broad chemical classes that we
have hypothesized interest in terms of their impacts on
prostate cancer, we are also employing an untargeted
exposomics approach to try to capture novel exposures,
potentially contributing to
prostate cancer within this population.
And so,
to conduct this assay,
we are conducting a high-resolution mass spec system
approach that will characterize various polar
molecules. These are
things like various organic compounds, pesticides,
some metals, and using GC mass
spec to capture volatile and semi-volatile chemical
exposures. So when you interrogate these measures against
a standard library, you potentially can characterize up to
2,000 known chemicals
using this analytical approach.
So just to give you
some preview of
the geographic variability that we see among
participants in the study, for example,
looking at the metals data, we see notable differences
in aluminum,
cobalt, chromium, iron, and manganese
concentrations among different regions that are
represented in this study, with many of these exposures
largely higher in more rural
regions where participants were recruited from.
And then, interestingly, we saw that there was a slight
increase of antimony within the
subsample that was recruited from Chicago.
So focusing
just on the Chicago participants, this is some data looking just at the
correlation of the various metals that were observed within these participants.
And we saw really the correlation ranged from
negligible to very high, suggesting that there are
multiple sources by which individuals are exposed to these metals.
And so,
the highest correlation that we observed was between nickel and
iron. So we think that these potentially might be industrial
exposures within certain industrial corridors that are
present in Chicago that may be leading to increased exposure
within those participants.
Just to give you a snapshot of some of the
characteristics of these participants.
So if we stratify individuals based
onLow risk versus high risk based on
ISUP grade.
We see that individuals with higher risk cancer generally were diagnosed
at a later
older age. There's notable differences in
educational attainment, with individuals who have high-risk
cancer having lower educational attainment,
and also individuals who have high-risk cancer
also being more likely to report current or former
cigarette smoking. And then, of course, we see a
significant difference in the distribution of PSA levels.
And so our key outcome
that we've focused on in terms of early characterization of some of
the environmental exposures has been using the
International Society of Urological Pathology, the
ISUP grade, which is based on the Gleason score,
as our metric for characterizing individuals as high versus low
risk.
And then we also have PSA levels as well as age at diagnosis
that we're looking at as well. And so, again, this is
preliminary data from the Chicago subsample.
But just looking sort of at the extremes of our findings,
we see that potentially antimony may be driving
increased risk based on ISUP grade, and
then
we see potentially protective effects of copper and
zinc with respect to that characterization.
And then
when we look at PSA levels, similar to the findings that we saw with
ISUP grade,
we see a protective effect of copper using
PSA as our
outcome of interest.
And then for age at diagnosis,
generally we're not seeing very many associations with age except for
maybe
a slightly protective association or inverse
association with chromium.
And so as I mentioned, in addition to looking at individual
exposures, we're also using methods to try to characterize mixture
effects. And so one
newly employed approach within the epidemiologic literature to
characterize mixtures,
one method is called quantile G computation, which
takes multiple chemicals that might be measured in your
study sample of interest,
and
provide a statistical approach for characterizing
the contribution of various elements within your
environmental mixture, the strength of that contribution, as well as
what the overall mixture effect is.
And so
based on this statistical model, we see
pretty consistent associations for manganese using our cancer risk
model as well as age at diagnosis. And then
looking at PSA levels, we see
arsenic contributing most strongly to the PSA model.
And then just to give you sort of a glimpse at some of the data that we're
seeing in terms of some of the other exposure measures.
As expected, we see regional variation with DDT and
DDE. So again, highest exposures are
largely seen in Vembe and Namibia,
where
these are more rural regions where DDT is being used for
malaria control. And so again, that's being represented in the data that we're
collecting from the study population.
And then when we look at associations of
DDT with
ISUP grade, particularly within Vembe, which
is the area where this is being used at much higher
levels,
we see clear dose response associations between exposure
levels with ISUP grade within this particular
geographic context.
And then within the untargeted
assay,
we've right now just generated data using silicone
wristbands, which is collecting ambient
environmental exposure data using these
wristbands among men in South Africa.
And so what this assay has shown us is that there are
about 51 chemicals that have been characterized in this population,
many of which have some
data or evidence to suggest that
they are related to carcinogenesis.
And so we're now beginning to explore approaches to be able to
characterize the impacts of these chemical exposures
with
cancer outcomes within this population.
And so I'd like to conclude by acknowledging the various
contributors across
really the world that are contributing to this work.
All right. Thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Dr. Argos, for that wonderful work.
I'd like to call to the stadium, Dr. Pelka.
Thank you so much. First of all, thank you so much, Dr.
Mitchell, for inviting me to this session.
I'm a huge fan of interdisciplinary research, and so I really love the
breadth of research that we span in this session.
My name is Karin Pelka. I'm from the Gladstone Institute in San Francisco.
And I'm going to take you now from the microenvironment all the way down to
the tumor microenvironment. And we'll talk about spatially organized immune
hubs, which are essentially hotspots of immune activity in the
tissue. So it's going to be a little bit different than the previous
talks.I have no relevant disclosures.
I will especially talk about one particular type
of immune hub today, which I will refer to as CXCL3 ligand hub,
that indicates T cell mediated immune attacks and tumors, and
we think that this could have important biomarker potential.
However, I do want to preface this talk very clearly with telling you
that I'm an immunologist who is doing discovery science, so
there's a lot more work needed to validate these discoveries in larger patient
cohorts to actually translate that into biomarkers.
What I do hope I will contribute to the discussion today, though, is
that we can find very conserved biology across
different disease contexts,
but how that then translates into actual patient outcome might be more
nuanced. So, in the first part of my talk, and this
is by far the longest part of my talk, I will introduce these CXCL3
ligand hubs in human colorectal cancer
and briefly show you
how these hubs can distinguish patients that are poised to respond to
immunotherapy and lung cancer. So, a good thing to have these
hubs in cancer.
And in the second much shorter part of my talk, I will show you how we find the
same type of CXCL3 ligand hubs in premalignancy, in this
case, in oral dysplasia patients.
And there they actually distinguish patients that are poised to progress to cancer.
So here they might serve as a warning sign telling us what
the lesions are that are at most risk to actually
progress.
As I mentioned, I'm an immunologist, so the main question in my lab is how
does the immune system operate in solid tumors?
You probably all know that we have these really potent killers in our body
called T cells that can be very potent in killing cancer cells.
But in solid tumors, the situation is a lot more complex.
So this is a human colorectal cancer specimen, and you can
see that the cancer cells are here, epithelial cells that are very tightly
packed and intermingled with the tumor stroma.
So for the immune cells to even find the cancer cells, they need to
navigate these really complex
environments. They need to talk to a lot of different cells and really
cannot function in isolation.
We think about the tumor stroma both as kind of the highways for the immune
cells. This is where the vessels are, but this is also where the fibroblasts are,
and this is also physical barriers that the immune cells need to overcome in order
to even get to the cancer cells they target.
So to understand how that actually works in human patients, we decided
to take a look at a success story.
And colon cancer is a really interesting
example here in this regard.
You might be familiar
with Andreas Zerbst's really inspiring work in rectal
cancer, where she found that a particular subset
of colorectal cancer patients shows really remarkable responses to
immunotherapy, in this case, checkpoint inhibitor anti-PD-1 therapy.
This particular subset are mismatch repair deficient rectal cancer
patients that show 100% complete response rates to
PD-1 blockade in locally advanced
disease.
So these are tumors that are very sizable, that already grew into the outermost
layers of the rectum
and maybe spread to lymph nodes. And within just a few months,
this tumor with just immunotherapy alone essentially melts away.
This is incredibly remarkable for the patients because prior standard of care
for these patients was a combination of neoadjuvant chemotherapy, radiation, and
then surgery.
So this is the example where we wanted to understand how immune responses
can be actually successful in tumors.
And we contrast that to the vast majority of colon cancer patients,
85% of all colon cancer patients, that do not have this
particular subtype. Instead, they're so-called mismatch repair
proficient tumors, and they essentially have no response to
immunotherapy.
So to understand how immune responses work in these two different settings, we did
a large single cell RNA sequencing study on 35 of these
immunotherapy responsive patients and 29 of the immunotherapy
non-responsive
subtype of colon cancer, performed single cell RNA sequencing
on around 400,000 individual transcriptomes.
We clustered that to discover the different cell types and states and gene
programs.
And then we used computational approaches to predict how these
different cell types and gene programs work together as functional units.
And the result of this computational analysis actually was
satisfyingly simple because we picked up on essentially three
major immune hubs.
The first is what I would
call an inflammatory hub. So this is an NF-kappa B
type of acute inflammatory reaction that brings myeloid
cells and granulocytes into the tumors.
The second I would refer to as tissue remodeling hub.
This is connected to this acute inflammatory hub and is characterized
by growth factors, angiogenesis, so a lot of things that we think might help
the tumor to grow.
And then the third one was especially interesting to us, and we named it
antitumor immunity hub because this one was only present in the
patients with this immunotherapy responsive subtype, this mismatch repair deficient
subtype.
And this hub was characterized by T cells, so the killers of our
immune system, especially activated and exhausted versions of that,
as well as interferon stimulated gene programs in myeloid cells and also the cancer
cells.
And so this work was published, but today I'm going to show
you unpublished work building on these, where we now took
these predictions and actually mapped these immune hubs
on tumor tissues with the idea that maybe we can
start to understand these very complex and patient specific
unique tumor immune landscapes as a combination
of just a small number of these conserved immune
hubs.And so we use single-cell resolved spatial
profiling methods to do that, specifically MERFISH and Xenium, and
the two projects that I'm going to show you are both large collaborative efforts.
So right off the bat,
it was actually quite exciting to see that the immune hubs that we predicted
were indeed present in these
tumors, and especially remarkably organized.
So this whole thing is showing you a primary colon cancer
specimen. Down here is the invasive margin.
This is the luminal margin,
where the epithelium is facing the lumen.
And this is in situ hybridization-based spatial transcriptomics.
So you see lots of tiny little dots, each dot is an individual
transcript.
And I just selected a few of the hundreds of transcripts that we measured,
and colored them, whether they were predicted to be part of these
inflammatory hubs, these anti-tumor immunity hubs, or these
well-known peri-tumoral lymphoid structures.
So right off the bat, you can see that these bluish colors are really present at
the luminal margin, suggesting that this really acute inflammatory
response in primary colon cancer is very
prominent at the luminal margin, where maybe damage is happening and
exposure potentially to the microbiome.
Whereas these anti-tumor immunity hubs shown in these yellow colors were
these little clusters throughout the tumor.
And I want to highlight, I'm not going to talk about that, but I want to highlight
that these anti-tumor immunity hubs are very distinct from
these larger lymphoid structures that contain T cells and B
cells
that in colon cancer are usually found below the
invasive margin of the tumor.
For the rest of the talk, I'm just going to focus on these anti-tumor immunity
hubs. And because the feature that really characterized them when we looked
at them spatially were the CXCL3 chemokines or CXCL9, 10, and
11, I'm going to rename them now to CXCL3 ligand hubs, so bear
with me.
First, we wanted to
validate that indeed, by defining CXCL3 ligand-rich
neighborhoods, we can rediscover the features
that we had predicted to be anti-tumor immunity hubs in our single-cell
study. And so you can see the top-enriched cell types in these CXCL3
ligand positive areas are interferon-stimulated gene
positive myeloid cells. This is a little circular because the CXCL3
ligands are part of interferon-stimulated gene signatures.
But then right next up here, position three, five, and six
are CXCL13 positive, CD8 positive, and CD4
positive T cells. So these are T cells, activated and
exhausted T cells, that have been found across different tumor studies
now as the T cells that are really enriched for tumor-reactive T
cells.
And we can also find dendritic cells, so another important myeloid cell type
that is important
in driving these anti-tumor responses.
So this matched up really nicely with the prediction from our prior
publication, the single-cell publication,
where we predicted that it's interferon gamma from these activated T cells
that's driving interferon-stimulated gene signatures in myeloid and malignant
cells. That part of these signatures are the CXCL3 ligands
or chemokines attractants for immune cells that can attract more
T cells and dendritic cells
into the tissue. And most of the T cells in our colon
cancer specimens we find in this more exhausted, dysfunctional state,
and a good marker here is CXCL13.
So the first question that we wanted to ask with these spatial data sets now is,
where are these CXCL3 ligand hubs localized
and how are they
organized?
And as I mentioned, this is a large collaborative effort
with Jonathan Chen, who now has his own lab at Northwestern, Ilya
Kruzynski's lab from Harvard, and Neha Kohn's
lab at the Broad Institute.
So going back to our big overview of the colon cancer specimen, I'm going
to now zoom into our small little area where we find one of these CXCL3
ligand hubs.
And I want to show you that these CXCL3 ligand hubs just by manual
assessment were really enriched at this
interface of the
colon cancer epithelial cells and the tumor stroma.
So in cyan here, you can see the stroma cells that are going through the
tumor.
So you can see these clusters of CXCL3 chemokine in yellow.
And these are areas where then we can see somewhat loose accumulations of
these red little immune cells.
So we quantify it if indeed our observation is correct, and
indeed, we find that there's very few cells in
CXCL3 ligand hubs that are in epithelial-only regions or in
stroma-only regions. And the vast majority, and each data point here is
a patient,
the vast majority really are in what we call now interface hubs, so
these hubs that span the stroma and epithelial
compartments of the tumor.
And consistent with our initial discovery of these hubs,
we mostly find these interface hubs in these immunotherapy
responsive subtypes of colon cancer, the mismatch repair deficient tumors.
So the next thing that we observed was that in these regions
of these CXCL3 ligand hubs, we saw that the immune cells did not
only accumulate in the stroma, but they actually
infiltrated the cancer's epithelium, so made close contact with the
actual cancer cells.
And when we looked what these cells are that make it into the cancer's
epithelium, most of them really had the genes
from these CXCL13 positive putative tumor-reactive T
cells.
And so again, we wanted to do a formal analysis for that.And
so for that, we now defined a spatial coordinate system.
The origin of the spatial coordinate system is this interface
between the cancer epithelium and the stroma.
And then we walk 100 micrometers from the stroma to this interface and then
into the epithelium and look what cell types are present.
So you can see, as expected, per definition, the epithelial cells are
essentially zero in the stroma and then almost 100% when
you're in the cancerous epithelium.
And you can also see that the myeloid cells and the T cells, or our immune cells,
are mostly on the stroma side of it.
Now, if you compare the orange and the green line, you can see that in these CX3CL1
hubs,
we see a significant enrichment of both myeloid cells and T cells
next to the interface.
We can now look at a more granular
characterization of these cells and find that many of the T
cells seem to spike right next to this interface.
Some have a broader distribution, like the regulatory T
cells, many spike right next to it, and this is also true for the myeloid
cells. But what also stood out is that indeed it was the
CD8 positive CX3CL1 positive T cells, so our killer
cells, that were able to significantly infiltrate it into the cancerous
epithelium.
So to summarize the first part of this talk, I introduced these CX3CL1
ligand hubs to you.
This originally came from our predictions, from the Cell
paper, where we described that tumors contain different types of
these conserved and spatially organized immune structures.
Using spatial profiling, we now showed that these CX3CL1 ligand hubs that we
originally called anti-tumor immunity hubs are enriched at the
stroma-epithelium interface, specifically of this
immunotherapy responsive subtype of colon cancer.
And we showed that there's a substructure of these hubs where we find very rich
interactions between T cells and myeloid cells on the stroma side of it,
and then, specifically CD8 positive CX3CL1 positive T
cells are able to infiltrate into the cancerous epithelium.
I just want to briefly call out a study that John Chen did where he
used our signatures now and applied them to a cohort of
non-small cell lung cancer patients.
And it was really exciting to see that in lung cancer, he finds
similar CX3CL1 ligand positive hubs,
at the stroma epithelial interfaces.
And the presence of them was strongly enriched in patients
that ended up responding to standard of care anti-PD-1 therapy.
He went one step further and defined a particular subtype of this
hub, which he called stem immunity hub,
where there were stem-like
T cells present right next to these CX3CL1 ligand areas, and that was
even more predictive. Just showing you that in
cancer, this hub seems to be predictive,
and are present across tumors,
but that also there might be particular subtypes of the hubs, and so the state of
the hub might be important as well.
For the last few minutes now, I want to switch gears and show you
another unpublished study, again, a large collaborative effort,
where we actually find these CX3CL1 ligand hubs now also in
premalignancy, and in this case, we're looking at oral dysplasia.
And here, interestingly, they really seem to distinguish patients that are poised
to progress to cancer. So again, might serve as a warning sign and tell
us where the immune system is detecting
lesions that might be dangerous.
So just to briefly introduce this project, and I'm really giving you only a very
brief sneak peek.
So this was a collaboration with Matt Spitzer's lab,
and Gabi Freigedag-Dagis' lab. Matt Spitzer put together a
really beautiful cohort of progressing versus non-progressing patients,
where these patients were followed over often
decades. And so we have lesions from their
oral dysplasia very early on, then longitudinal samples
until they either progress to cancer or remain progression free.
And I'm going to only talk about the very first dysplasia sample,
so this is years before the patients eventually ended up
getting cancer. And I'm going to show you how even in this very earliest lesion,
we can already find immune features that seem to distinguish these
progressing patients.
As just some background for this disease, oral epithelial dysplasia
frequently precedes oral squamous cell carcinoma,
and the rate of malignant transformation is actually very variable.
Some studies report 2%, some 33%, depending on
other features.
And the big problem is that existing histopathologic predictors like
grade are really poor predictors of progression.
And so coming in with an immunological mindset, we asked if maybe
there are certain immune features that might distinguish these patients.
What's really interesting is that right from the start, the
feature that really stood out to best predict the patients that end
up progressing were exactly these CX3CL1 CD8 positive T
cells that we found to be part of these CX3CL1 ligand hubs, in
our cancers. And the second one you can see are these interferon stimulated gene
positive macrophages and then dendritic cells.
So exactly the same
cell types that we predicted to be part of these CX3CL1 ligand hubs in cancer.
And again, in this case, they're higher in the progressing patients.
When we then looked where they're localized, again, the biology was actually very
conserved. So we could find that these CX3CL1 CD8 positive T cells were
infiltrating the epithelium,
and this is true for progressers, whereas you can find very little of those
cells in the non-progressing patients.
We then used unbiased analyses, in
this case, Cell Charter, to identify the neighborhoods,
and essentially picked up on exactly these two parts of these CX3CL1 ligand hubs
that we had found in cancer beforenamely
a neighborhood that we call epi immune.
This is the region where the CXCR3, CXCL13
positive CD8 T cells infiltrate the epithelium, and then the
stroma activated neighborhood right below, where we
see these really rich interactions between T cells and myeloid cells.
And this is exactly in regions that are marked by these CXCR3 ligands.
And then if we look which of the neighborhoods are
characteristic for the progressing patients, again, it was really
the epi immune neighborhood. So the neighborhood with the CXCL13 positive T
cells infiltrate into the epithelium, what was significantly higher
in the progressing patients. Whereas the stroma part of the hub wasn't
significantly different, and neither were these other immune neighborhoods
that are more similar to lymphod structures.
So with this, I want to summarize, I showed you this slide already at the
start,
but we were really excited to see that these CXCR3 ligand hubs seem to
be very conserved biology and define T
cell-mediated immune attacks at the stroma epithelial interface.
We do think, as I mentioned, that maybe that could be an important biomarker,
but also I think these two stories highlight how
translating that into what it actually means for patient outcome can be quite
difficult.
I showed you that in oral dysplasia or premalignancy,
having these hubs really was a warning sign to identify the lesions
that were most likely to progress to cancer.
And previously, I showed you that the same hubs,
when they're still present in cancer, actually mark the patients that are most
likely to respond to immunotherapy.
Of course, it's now really
exciting to postulate that maybe
indeed the patients that are at most risk to
progress might also be the patients that in premalignancy already benefit the
most for immunotherapy, and I think
there's some exciting work going on in this direction.
So with this, I would like to thank everyone.
As I mentioned, both of those studies were actually large collaborative efforts.
So the first study on colon cancer
was work done by Han Chen, together with Mukta
Palshikar, and Jingya Qiu,
and Edja Kosinski's lab, John Chen's lab, and Neha Kohn's lab, together with my
lab.
And then the second part was a project that really started in Matt Spitzel's
lab and was a close collaboration also with Gabi Dranques's lab.
And here the key people driving the work were Jingya Qiu,
who is joint between our labs,
Sax Stensland and Qin Li.
Thank you so much.
Okay, so we have some time for questions.
Any questions?
Come up to the mic.
Yes, I would like to address the last talk. Thank you very much.
I'm curious,
where are the CXCR5 positive cells that these
CXCL13 producing cells are going, and your CD4s,
they're probably follicular T helper cells that
are PD-1 high.
So on your CD8s and your CD4s, is the level of
PD-1 really high?
Yeah. So the PD-1 level is very high on both the CD4 and the CD8 T
cells.
We were really looking for these CXCR5 positive cells in the tumor,
but we can't really find any CXCR5 positive cells associated with
the hubs in colon cancer. In the lung cancer study, where you
have these more progenitor-like TCF7 high cells,
those
have CXCR5 expressed as well. So maybe there,
those cells are being attracted. But in colon cancer, we neither
find B cells nor CXCR5 positive T cells in the hub, suggesting
that maybe there's something else that's holding them back and not enabling
these cells to get into the tumor. The cells that we find in the
tumor, the CXCR3 positive cells, the CD4 cells, do
not have T follicular helper cell phenotypes.
It's really these putative tumor-reactive T cells,
in some studies in rheumatoid arthritis, they were described as like
peripheral helper cells, but they're distinct
from the follicular helper cells that we find in the lymphod structures that are
below the invasive margin.
So the T follicular helper cells that produce
CXCL13 do not express CXCR5. They down-regulate
it, and we believe the same is true for the CD8s.
But the question is: Why are they producing CXCL13?
What are they trying to attract to themselves?
Do you have any idea on that?
Yeah, it's a great question. We have
some thoughts, but we haven't really
investigated that properly.
One thought is that the CXCL13, while it's expressed on
transcriptional level and other studies show that it's also actually present on
protein level,
might be
siphoned up in the tumor, so maybe there's not a proper gradient.
That would be one
hypothesis.
And another hypothesis would be that somehow, you can definitely see
that the B cells, they kind of line up, and others have shown that as well, they
kind of line up at the invasive margin, that there's something specific that
prevents these cells from getting into
the tumor.
And if you cut through, you don't find B cells?
Because you're looking in two dimensions, so if you cut through the block,
what you see if you go 100 microns is you get different cell
types and different activities.
That's correct. But these CX3 ligand hub step we see are not these
B cell containing tertiary lymphoid structures.
We did single cell
RNA sequencing from different parts of the tumor.
We looked at different regions. We do not find B cells there.
The B cells are really in these tertiary lymphoid structures and then kind of
enriched at the invasive margin, but it's outside of the tumor in
colon cancer.
They can also be inside the tumor, but I would suggest you look
at the protein for CXCL13. I think there's a disconnect
sometimes between the RNA and the protein.
Yeah, we actually stained for that too, and we find it.
It's actually quite beautiful. So I think it's present, but
your question is excellent. We do not know why
they don't really seem to get in there more. Yeah.
Okay. Thanks.
Thank you.
Thank you all for very illuminating talks.
I have three questions. The first one for Dr. Mitchell.
For radon, apart from somatic and
germline, is any epigenetics involved?
So that's the first question. And then the second question was for
Dr. Argos. When you compare
regions like in Namibia and Kenya that are agricultural versus
industrial, if you stratify by that, do you see
any commonalities in the HDR defects or is
it just it's DNA damage, so it doesn't matter?
And then the third and final question to all three is how do you
define exposome in terms of how
long do you have to be exposed to be... Is there early versus late?
Is epigenetic in the early stage and then somatic and--
So how do you define it in terms of time for you to be
collecting? Could you stratify if you expose for one month,
two years, ten years? How long do you look at that? Thank you.
Thank you for those questions.
I'll start. So yes, there have been some studies that looked at DNA
methylation changes, not necessarily histone or non-coding
changes as far as it relates to radon exposure.
And they've seen, particularly these studies were done in minors and people who
live in high radon areas, and it's shown that DNA methylation changes have been
enriched in DNA repair pathways. Not
necessarily HR, but overall like DNA repair.
Second, as far as the exposome.
So it takes about ten years post-exposure of radon to
develop what we believe is radon induced lung cancer.
So typically that's the window. The challenge is the dissymmetry
because like I mentioned, we have different biological susceptibility.
When we think about radon in my group, in my team, we
are similar to what Dr. Argos said, looking at toenails because that can give
you a snapshot of ten years worth of cumulative exposure to
the radon.
And to address the question about
rural versus urban and then some of the commonality.
So with respect to the environmental data,
we're just beginning to
generate and analyze that data. And so our goal
really is to look at associations sort
of within country and then within region.
And then once we see what those associations are, begin to,
if we can, collapse across the sites to look at
more
global impacts of the exposure. So, I will say we haven't
at this stage gone very deep in those analyses because we're still waiting
on data. And then in terms of the exposome, this
is a very complicated question because
it's exposure specific and endpoint specific.
And so, I would say if somebody has a very
short acute exposure to something,
for some outcomes it might have
some impacts. Whereas for other environmental exposures
you really need kind of chronic exposure to see the impacts
of
that environmental factor. So
it's extraordinarily complicated, I think, to be able to answer that
question. Yeah.
Okay. I'm going to have a question for Karen. Awesome work.
I was wondering if you thought about the intratumoral heterogeneity in
patients, right? Because you mentioned these CXCR3
ligands immunity hubs, and that they correlate with
responders, right, to immune checkpoint blockade.
But do you see within the same tumors, the same patient, can
you also find immune hubs that actually look more
immunosuppressive? And then is there some kind of a
ratio or balance that can really
correspond to
patients responding or not responding to treatment?
Yeah. Excellent question. We definitely see that in tumors,
the landscape is not uniform. So in some
tumors you can see these hubs very prevalent in one part of the tumor,
and they're completely absent in another, or in some tumors you can only see
them more at the invasive margin. So it can be quite
heterogeneous.
And I do think it starts to get much more complicated when you start to look
on treatment. There's a lot of work now with neoadjuvant treatment
showing that actually you can induce these similar type of
signatures
in patients with treatment, and then it does not necessarily tell you if these
patients will respond or not. Like some signs of immune activity you're going to
see with treatment. And so this is where we're really
interested in understanding. So we almost start to look at these
hubs-as a type of response, where now we want
to understand what the stage of this response is.
So maybe if you see these stem immunity hubs where there are more
stem-like T cells, maybe that's really what you need in order to respond.
Whereas if you see very chronic interferon stimulated gene signatures, maybe that's
really what's driving
resistance to treatment. So maybe it's kind of a continuum, and so
understanding exactly
at what stage the response is, I think will be really important.
We start to address it now in preclinical model systems.
But yeah, in patients it's always tricky because usually you get a snapshot
here and there. So yeah, I think the answer for that is still
out.
Thank you.
I have a follow-up question for Dr.
Argos on some of the environmental factors.
We are starting up a cancer epidemiology cohort, and
I've been struggling because
a lot of our community members would very much like to see
environmental exposures measured.
Do you have any advice or, in your dream world, what would
you like
cohorts to be gathering in terms of either
self-reported or objective measures for
environmental exposure? Any advice is well appreciated.
Yeah, thanks for that comment.
And this is a US-based cohort?
Yes.
Yeah. So I think
within US-based studies, potentially you have the advantage of
collecting residential history, and so there's quite a bit
of information that you can link based on residence
that will go back in time, right? So probably you can
pretty accurately go back 20 years based on just residential
information.
However,
for a lot of the work that I'm doing, we're relying on the collection of biological
specimens. And so, there the challenge is that
you're limited to whatever the half-life of the chemical is, which is often
very short, and so we're collecting recent exposure.
So if you have the opportunity to collect longitudinal
samples, depending on whether you're looking at cancer
onset or cancer prognosis, having
samples that you can look across time to strengthen the measures that you
have, I think would be very helpful.
But I think between
external exposome and internal exposome, I think
the complement of those two would be very valuable in the context of a
US study.
Okay, well, we're at the top of the hour, so thank you all for coming to our
session. Enjoy the rest of the conference.